on fouille on farfouille au festival de
la bande dessinée de buc les amoureux ne
peuvent s'empêcher et parfois trouver
les trésors en charge des pépites et
surtout celle là où et ça monsieur des
passionnés qui a monté sa propre
voilà des petits fascicules comme ça à
tonnerre de bull a book un bouquet alors
books est un écrivain avec un
dessinateur écrivain magnifique et du
coup je les trouvais chez lui les
séquençages trésor mais le festival
c'est avant tout un moment de rencontres
avec les auteurs et illustrateurs près
d'une cinquantaine de professionnels ont
fait le déplacement cette année c'était
un peu partie du travail de
se prêter au jeu de la promotion pendant
un certain temps surtout dans l'album
est fraîchement sorti quelques mois
belge bien voir marc védrines du coup
mais c'est pas pour moi c'est pour
quelqu'un d'autre moi j'ai pas grandi
dans cette culture de bd parce que
je suis allemande et
il n'y a pas trop ça mais mon mari aime
beaucoup les bd
les enfants aussi du coup je suis ravi
il
super choix la jeunesse n'est pas mise
de côté au milieu des passionnés des
enfants qui ne peuvent s'empêcher
d'aller voir leurs créateurs préférés et
rock
l'auteur des profs chaque mois c'est
amusant et j'aime bien ces personnages
ça ça nous rappelle le collège et les
auteurs qu'on voit ça nous rappelle les
professeurs j'ai quand même une série
qui commence à voir quelques années mais
j'ai des nouveaux lecteurs donc des
enfants ça ça fait plaisir parce que le
risque c'est que les lecteurs
vieillissant même temps que les auteurs
etc les séries de bd
une affluence record de la part des
bédéphiles cette année a vu plus de huit
mille passionnés ont cherché à rapporter
un souvenir personnalisé